bonjour à toutes et à tous
et bienvenue pour ce nouvel épisode de easy french news
le 8 septembre 2025
le premier ministre François Bayrou
a perdu un vote de confiance
à l'Assemblée nationale
par 364 voix contre
et 194 voix pour
c'est la première fois depuis la création
de la 5e République
qu'un gouvernement est renversé de la sorte
le lendemain le 9 septembre
il a officiellement remis sa démission
au président Emmanuel Macron
et reste en place
uniquement pour gérer les affaires courantes
en attendant la nomination d'un nouveau gouvernement
Emmanuel Macron devrait désigner son successeur
dans les jours qui viennent
peut-être dès cette semaine
cette démission
survient après un budget très controversé
44 milliards d'euros d'économie
y compris la suppression de jours fériés
dans un contexte de dette publique élevée
et d'opposition de la plupart des partis politiques
français
la Belgique a annoncé qu'elle allait reconnaître
officiellement l'état de Palestine devant l'ONU
en plus de cette décision symbolique
elle prépare 12 sanctions contre Israël
par exemple l'interdiction
d'importer des produits fabriqués
dans les colonies israéliennes
cette annonce arrive dans un contexte de guerre à Gaza
la situation humanitaire est dramatique
manque de nourriture
hôpitaux débordés
milliers de morts
la décision belge crée un débat en Europe
certains pays pourraient suivre cet exemple
tandis que d'autres plus proches d'Israël
critiquent ce choix
le 2 septembre l'armée américaine
a attaqué un bateau près des côtes du Venezuela
selon Washington
ce navire appartenait au cartel criminel
Tren de Aragua
un groupe très puissant dans le trafic de drogue
en Amérique latine
l'opération aurait fait 11 morts
mais le Venezuela rejette totalement ses accusations
le gouvernement affirme que la vidéo
diffusée par les Américains est truquée
et accuse Washington de vouloir déstabiliser le pays
cette incident
montre la tension croissante entre les deux pays
les États-Unis veulent
lutter contre le trafic de drogue
mais le Venezuela y voit une atteinte à sa souveraineté
le 3 septembre
la Chine a organisé à Pékin un immense défilé militaire
pour commémorer
la victoire sur le Japon
en 1945
plus de 12.000 soldats ont participé
le président Xi Jinping
a annoncé un discours très ferme
il a déclaré que la Chine ne se laissera jamais
intimidée et qu'elle poursuit
sa renaissance nationale
de nombreux observateurs voient dans ce défilé
une démonstration de force
la Chine veut montrer qu'elle est une grande puissance
militaire
à un moment où les tensions sont fortes en Asie
notamment avec Taiwan et les États-Unis
le Z event un grand marathon caritatif en ligne
organisé à Montpellier et sur Twitch
s'est déroulé le weekend du 4 au 7 septembre
il y a eu un concert d'ouverture le 4 septembre
puis 3 jours de streaming pour récolter des dons
cette édition soutient 7 associations
dans les domaines de la santé
et de l'enfance
par exemple la Ligue contre le cancer
cette année l'événement a établi un nouveau record
à 16 millions d'euros
qui ont été récoltés
soit beaucoup plus que les années précédentes
voilà pour ce nouveau format qui
est plus orienté sur l'actualité
je vais en sortir un par semaine
donc si vous aimez le format abonnez-vous
si cette vidéo est un peu trop facile pour vous
je vous recommande la chaîne d'Hugo
Décrypte dont je me suis inspiré
c'est la même chose
en mieux bien sûr et dans un français fluent
donc c'est plus difficile à comprendre
merci d'avoir regardé jusqu'au bout
je vous dis à la prochaine